partir d'ici ça tourne à ok vas dit ok
l'heure est grave je suis sous les
quarts pour la troisième fois en moins
de six mois ils sont en train de péter
complètement la rue donc ces marteaux
piqueurs et compagnie donc je me
retrouve à tourner dans la réserve
parce que sinon vous n'allez rien
entendre salut dimanche dernier dans une
vidéo de mcfly et carlito big lots à
deviner le prénom de quelqu'un sans
aucun indice au canada mais ce qui est
vraiment intéressant c'est que à la fin
il a dit ça les amis c'est très simple
il va voir un inconnu qui veut entrer
dans cette pièce le connaissait pas et
on va devoir deviner son prénom - je le
sens valentin je dois répondre
maintenant je dois tu dois dire oui ou
non
merci quoi tu te souviens de ton pote
d'enfance voilà je trouvais qu'il lui
ressemble un peu et j'ai dit voilà
regarder leur catatonie cette réflexion
est plus qu'intéressante est très
pertinente et un petit peu passé
inaperçu mais le fait que big flo
s'inspire des prénoms des personnes
qu'il a rencontrées dans sa vie ont
augmenté ses chances de trouver le bon
prénom depuis 2010 est sa porte un nom
il ya eu des études dessus ça s'appelle
l'effet d'ariane gré on va en parler
aujourd'hui dans la vidéo et vous allez
pouvoir tester l'effet sur vous c'est
parti loïc générique c'est le générique
de la vidéo de fabien olicard sur
l'effet de or dorion
oui tu va pas refaire ça a fait un vrai
génériques ok
[Musique]
ce dont on va parler aujourd'hui c'est
complètement dingue ça peut paraître
complètement irrationnel alors que c'est
de la science durant cette vidéo je vais
vous faire voir des images avec un
sondage et des propositions de prénoms
et vous allez devoir essayer de deviner
le prénom des personnes que vous allez
voir à l'image tout a commencé avec une
étude franco israélienne publié le 27
février 2010 est dans le journal suivant
journal of personality and social
psychologie j'espère loïc que tu as
trouvé l'image
l'idée de base est très simple un prénom
déteindrait sur le visage de la personne
qui le porte
d'où le nom de cet effet d'ariane gré en
référence au roman d'oscar wilde ou le
jeune homme possède un tableau qui prend
très cher à sa place à chaque fois qu'il
fait la fête c'est un résumé très simple
je veux dire qu'ils sont plus du tout
fini les travaux un peu du tout d'accord
et aussi pour te dire qu'on entend très
bien les bureaux d'un côté quand on est
dans cet endroit c'est vrai oui enfin je
pense qu'elles soient optimales à la ba
écoute c'est parfait voilà du coup je
tâte à une tête de loïc toi c'est vrai
du coup tu vas monter les vidéos qu'on
peut pas tourner c'est ça ok super ça
c'est parfait allez merci donc notre
visage serait tellement marqué par notre
prénom qu'on serait capable de deviner
le prénom de quelqu'un juste en
regardant son visage avec quelques
conditions évidemment en partant de
l'hypothèse que nos caractéristiques
physiques pouvait épouser les
stéréotypes de nos prénoms des
chercheurs israéliens ont mis au point
un test où ils ont montré des photos de
20 personnes dont il y avait dix hommes
et dix femmes qui avaient un visage
neutre et où chaque photo avait une
proposition de quatre prénoms différents
et parmi les quatre se trouver le bon
la même expérience a été ensuite trophée
en france mais ce coup ci avec des
visages et des prêts non rattachés à la
culture française et au final ce sont
huit études qui ont été réalisées sur ce
principe en france et en israël
et les résultats ont été identiques les
huit fois il y a eu 35 à 40 % de bonnes
réponses sur le choix des quatre prénoms
avec sur certaines photos des réussites
allant jusqu'à 80% 80% 80% je ne sais
pas si vous voyez à quel point quand
même c'est énorme c'est juste ouf c'est
à dire que le hasard aurait voulu qu'on
avoisine toujours les 25% de bonnes
réponses là c'est pas hasard de ses 35 à
40 % avec des pics jusqu'à 80%
j'insiste beaucoup parce que je trouve
ça officines mais et c'est ça qui est
intéressant de la phrase qu'a dit big
flo il faut avoir soi-même
théréau type du prénom qu'on recherche
c'est à dire avoir rencontré au moins
une personne voire plusieurs danses
habituant ce prénom la y avoir créé
inconsciemment un stéréotype de cette
personne-là lire ce prénom
en gros je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
après cette étude prouve que quand tu te
dis tiens cette personne me fait penser
à telle autre personne
alors il ya de fortes chances qu'ils
aient le même prénom
alors évidemment tout n'est pas si
simple dans le cas des prénoms rares par
exemple même si les résultats sont au
dessus du hasard ils sont quand même
moins bluffant c'est également le cas
des prénoms trop fréquent quand un
prénom est trop fréquents et qu'on a
rencontré trop de personnes qui
portaient ce prénom là alors ça bouzzine
autres stéréotypes ce même pas que ça le
blues il sait qu'il n'ya plus de
stéréotypes de base qu'on pourrait avoir
lié à ce prénom parce qu'on a rencontré
trop de personnalités différentes liées
aux prénoms et bien sûr ça ne fonctionne
que si on appartient à la même culture
de la personne présente sur la photo
qu'on est de la même génération de la
même ethnie et potentiellement de la
même catégorie sociale c'est l'effet
tribus qui s'applique où on reconnaît
les personnes membres de notre propre
tribu c'est quand même très étrange de
se dire que nous qui prenons le
caractère unique de chaque personne
on puisse se fier à quelque chose
d'aussi contre-intuitif
intellectuellement parlant je parle qu
un stéréotype
on va enchaîner avec le test que vous
allez pourvoir faire là vous maintenant
avec quatre photos différentes j'en
profite aussi pour remercier ma nombril
c'est elle qui l'année dernière en 2017
m'avait fait parvenir cette étude là il
m'a fait découvrir sa merci beaucoup
bien dans la description elle est
géniale jeu mais également en
descriptions quelques liens pour ceux
qui veulent aller un petit peu plus loin
mais également un lien vers le site de
slate.fr
ils ont fait un article en février
dernier sur ce sujet qui est très bien
fait très intéressant et surtout ils
sont amusés à remettre des photos neutre
dessus avec des prénoms différents et
c'est celle ci qu'on va utiliser donc je
les utilise là mais vous en contrepartie
à les tchèques et leurs articles voilà
échange de bons procédés
vous pourrez aussi voir les résultats
que ça a donné chez eux où il ya quand
même 65 mille personnes qui ont répondu
le premier visage apparaît à l'écran
alors c'est un visage neutre d'après
vous c'est un visage de quoi de
sébastien de tomates de maxime ou de
vincent il a une tête de quel prénom
comme ça que l'on vous voyez son visage
vous dit j'ai une tête à s'appeler voilà
faites confiance à votre intuition
stéréotype est ce qu on appelle souvent
l'intuition c'est juste l'inconscient
qu'à stocker des infos et qui vous les
donne comme ça je vous laisse quelques
secondes assez courte pour être les
chiffres et vous avez au dessus de moi
un sondage où vous pouvez mettre votre
réponse
ce temps là je je me balade dans ce
grand nouveau décor que vraiment je suis
très très heureux d'avoir grâce aux
travaux deuxième tête voici un nouveau
visage cette jeune femme elle s'appelle
emilie elodie aurélie ou amélie vous
avez les quatre propositions qui sont
écrites autour de moi réfléchissez à la
tête de l eau
je dis rien non c'est quelque chose ça
change tout vous avez toujours le
sondage au dessus de moi pour répondre à
les y est on passé la troisième photo
troisième photo elle apparaît maintenant
est ce que cette jeune femme s'appelle
audrey amélie aurélie ou aurore
réfléchissez mais pas trop longtemps
aller piocher encore une fois dans un
oui elle a une bonne tête de quelque
chose est voté au dessus je vais encore
passer quelques secondes parce que sinon
les votes ne peuvent pas réapparaître il
faut je crois au moins cinq ou six
secondes à chaque fois entre chaque vote
quatrième et dernier essai donc 4e
photos maintenant est ce que c'est un
cédric à nicolas arnaud ou un sébastien
c'est votre dernier choix c'est la
dernière fois que je chante comme ça
alors cédric nicolas arnaud sébastien et
puis une autre question c'est pourquoi
ils sont pas bien aligner les noms loïc
quoi vous avez choisi vous votez au
dessus on passe à la suite je vous donne
les résultats dans quelques minutes à
peine je veux juste revenir sur ce qui
va nous pousser à réfléchir un peu plus
loin l'interprétation des résultats de
ces études qui ont été menées par hec
paris l'université de jérusalem le idc
et l'université de colombie les ont
amenés à l'hypothèse suivante le prénom
que l'on reçoit est déjà plein de
stéréotypes inconscient pour l'entourage
de la personne cet entourage va
interagir avec l'enfant comme s'il avait
déjà les personnalités liées aux
stéréotypes deux personnalités
évidemment qu'ils ont face à ce prénom
voyez ce que je veux dire et en
conséquence indirecte notre prénom peut
changer notre propre perception de
nous-mêmes et influencer l'apparence de
notre visage la manière qu'on a de
s'habiller de se préparer de se
maquiller pour les filles d'avoir une
barbe comme ci ou comme ça pour les
garçons est évidemment quelque chose
d'encore plus visible c'est la coupe de
cheveux qu'on choisit d'avoir pour ceux
qui prennent le temps de se coiffer à ce
jour et ça c'est fabuleux on n'a pas
encore de données qui nous permettent de
comprendre pourquoi ça donne ses
résultats
art pour ça qu'on est juste sur des
hypothèses de cause et tout ça paraît
complètement irrationnel alors que c'est
complètement factuel mais une chose est
sûre c'est que au delà du genre de notre
ethnie et de notre catégorie sociale
le prénom c'est le premier marqueur
social qu'on a vis-à-vis des autres mais
ce ne serait pas un marqueur social et
dans le fond je trouve ça fabuleux parce
que je fais des spectacles depuis
presque dix ans et je rencontre
énormément de monde sur scène et
régulièrement
je ne suis pas étonné que la personne
est le prénom qu'elle l'a quand je lui
demande pectacle que vous continuez à
retrouver en tournée ici
lalalalalalalalala et des fois c'est
complet c'est pour ça que vous réservez
liens dans la description toi même tu
sais voici maintenant le résultat des
quatre prénoms que vous avez vu j'espère
que cette vidéo vous a plu
prenez une seconde pour la ligue et si
c'est le cas ce premier visage vous
aviez le choix entre sébastien thomas
maxime où vincent et c'est un vincent
pour information quand moi j'ai fait le
test j'avais pensé que c'était un maxime
j'avais il faut à celui ci deuxième
photo vous aviez le choix entre emilie
et l'audi aurélie et amélie est cette
personne s'appelle elodie est
effectivement moi j'avais bien me elodie
aussi et ça m'avait fait bugger de ouf
troisième photo vous aviez le choix
entre audrey amélie aurélie ou aurore
est là elle s'appelle aurore est là
aussi
j'avais trouvé le prénom est là aussi
j'ai acheté mes watts et enfin la
dernière photo cédric nicolas arnaud
sébastien personnellement j'avais hésité
entre sébastien et arnaud j'avais me
arnaud et c'est arnaud c'est le
générique de la faim l'avait relooking
ballon mais c'est parce que c'est pour
l'annoncer que c'est la fin de la vidéo
il reste juste quelques jours les gens
ne vont pas rester fais pas ça messi
mais parce que comme ça moi je fais la
chanson comme ça non plus à la fin je
mets un truc de ouf
allez d'accord cool vous pouvez vous
abonner en cliquant ici et comme ça vous
ne raterez pas les une à deux vidéos par
semaine qui sortent en général le
mercredi matin et le samedi matin
ici vous avez une vidéo que youtube vous
recommande de regarder parce qu'ils
connaissent votre algorithmes ne s'est
pas un stéréotype ils savent tout de
vous ici c'est la dernière vidéo qui est
sortie qui était très très cool
à très bientôt ciao